we could speak now to the chief
executive of NHS Confederation that
represents a whole Healthcare System in
England Wales and Northern Ireland
that's Matthew Taylor he joins us now
live from Leeds thank you for being with
us
um I'm interested to get your take on
the interview with Stephen Buckley first
he said he wants a bonfire of the NHS
pen pushers cutting bureaucrats axing
targets for efficiency savings is that a
good idea
yeah I mean I'm not sure about the kind
of slightly populist language of pen
pushers and red tape and all of that I
mean actually the the issue here
is that the National Health Service is
very uh centralized hierarchical system
and it generates an enormous number of
targets now some of those targets
actually come from politicians
themselves
so I strongly support the idea that we
should try to devolve more power
so that local health systems working
with Partners like local government can
find solutions that work for them too
often these National systems create
everywhere as if it's the same and
places
um are very different and the secretary
of state is appointed Patricia Hewitt
and of course was Health Secretary of
State way back in the barriers to try to
look at how we can devolve power in the
Health Service so we can assess our
local Solutions so we absolutely support
that we think it's a very good idea
um we are seeing you know I'm interested
to know about the state of the Health
Service because we're seeing of course
long waits in a e we're seeing struggles
to get GP appointments and we of course
go about to go up into winter and the
time when the NHS is under most pressure
are you actually a bit worried about the
health of the NHS right now
yes we are in the midst of a a gap and
that's the gap between the demand that
we face and the capacity we've got so on
the one hand we have an aging population
so for example the year of our lives are
we consuming the most amount of Health
and Care results it's the last year of
our life and over the next decade
there'll be about 25 more people
reaching the last year of their life so
you've got population aging you've got
repent up demands of covid you've got
unfortunately the fact that as a country
we have high levels of poverty poverty
is stroke is is strongly connected to
ill health is your last interview
vividly demonstrated so we've got a lot
of demand but then when it comes to
capacity we had 10 years of austerity
when growth in Health Service spending
was around half of what most economists
say that we need that meant we went into
covert there was a research last week
that showed this about about 40 billion
pounds less have been invested in the UK
in comparison to EU countries in that
decade leading up to Cobalt so we go
into covid with over a hundred thousand
vacancies with a crumbling estate lack
of investment in in psychiat and covet
hits us extremely hard the effects that
covert had in terms of for example
waiting lists was much worse in the UK
because we just didn't have the extra
capacity so we've come out of that and
this is the issue this gap between
demand and capacity now you know we
welcome the fact the secretary of state
has got more money out of the treasury
to deal with the impact of inflation
it's not as much as we need not as much
as we want but we're grateful for
anything that we can get
but what we really need now is
consistent spending over the next five
or ten years and we've got to address
these two fundamental issues 130 000
vacancies in hell so it's 160 000 in
Social and a 10 billion pound backlog in
terms of the estate and it's only when
we fundamentally address those capacity
issues that we're going to get the
Health Service that we need and that we
want
it's interesting for you to talk though
about you know the health of the Health
Service going into uh covid because of
course you know minister is very keen to
talk about the impact of the pandemic
exclusively
um now you're talking about the
challenges of
um extra Demand with the Aging
population and how much more Health
Service we consume in the later years of
Our Lives
now the NHS of course is consuming an
increasing amount of public spending I
think it's a almost 200 billion pounds a
year 20 of public spending continuing to
rise
is the problem that actually money isn't
the only solution that we need reform as
well
I I do think we can do things better I
think we can be more productive but the
problem is that some of the ways in
which we're not productive are a
reflection of that lack of investment so
let me give you a couple of examples we
spend a lot of money on agency staff and
that's a very expensive way of employing
people but that's because we don't have
that Workforce strategy so one of the
things I really welcome about the Autumn
statement is a commitment by the
government to have a proper medium-term
Workforce strategy take another example
almost every hospital in England in
Wales in Northern Ireland has got Wards
full of people who could go home who
should go home hospitals are not a good
place for me to be if you don't need to
be there you get in a deconditioned your
your situation tends to kind of
deteriorate now it costs more to have
people in hospitals than it does to have
them in Care Homes and a lot more than
it does to have them getting domiciliary
care but we don't have that social Care
staff the lack of investment in capital
means that services like Primary Care
aren't as efficient as they as they
ought to be so we can be more productive
but it's not about kind of you know
cutting away at bureaucracy actually we
have fewer managers in the Health
Service than than most other kind of
systems large large systems like ours
it's about that medium-term investment
in a Better Health Service a Health
Service for example that could be better
at diagnostic so we we find diseases uh
earlier so we all want a more productive
Health Service we all want a Better
Health Service and to be fair to the
Secretary of State I think many of
things he's talking about whether it's
data I.T evolving power are in the right
direction
but it's going to take time you know we
are not in the situation we want to be
in the demand is growing and it is going
to take time for us to rebuild the
health
I'm talking about social care were you
disappointed that there wasn't more
about social care in the Autumn
statement
well there's some more money for social
care I mean the government faced a
difficult Choice which is that most of
the extra money that was dedicated to
social care and the Austria's Autumn
statement was going towards the cap on
social care costs now the government has
put that off for two years that's an
unpopular thing to do but by doing that
there's more money which can go into the
front line and I I think on balance
given that resources are limited that
was probably the right thing to do
because when you've got a hundred and
seventy thousand 160 000 vacancies in
Social care the situation just grinds to
a whole
and if you talk to anyone in local
government who's trying to recruit
people into social care the fact is that
you know cost of living crisis is hard
for everyone but the private sector in
the end can pass on extra costs it can
raise wages and I I speak to people
every day who work in Health and Social
care and they talk about staff leaving
to go and work in warehouses to go and
work in retail something which
intensifies in Crystal so that situation
is deteriorating so in a perfect world
there'd be more money for social care in
the front line and we'd be able to carry
out the reforms that Boris Johnson
unveiled some time ago but given the
choices the really important thing is to
get that money to the front line and and
two for example get those people out of
Hospital who don't need to be there
it's interesting as well to hear talking
about the um issue with staff in the
hospitals but also in Social care as
well his brexit had an impact on that
there's no question that brexit is part
of this and the government themselves
uh has taken measures uh to bring more
staff in from around the world because
you know we have Labor shortages
everywhere and they're particularly
acute in Health and Care because we
don't pay very much and because the work
is extremely demanding but yes brexit
cut off as supply of labor and we've had
to Scrabble around now to try and bring
in people because you know without
overseas staff our NHS simply would not
work
and then finally and you know hundreds
of thousands of nurses have voted to
strike
how much
is that going to have on a Health
Service this winter that as we've
already talked about is already feeling
a lot of pressure
well to be fair to be asked yen in the
unions they've committed to the fact
that they will not disrupt emergency or
critical care but clearly as you say
Health Service under kind of pressures
I've described
industrial action is just another
pressure on top of that and I welcome
the fact that the secretary of state is
keeping negotiations open keeping
discussions open uh with the unions the
government has committed to Bringing
forward the pay review for next year so
hopefully hopefully there are grounds
for finding
um a way through this but it's important
to say that you know even if the trade
unions weren't at weren't threatening
industrial action
with the 130 000 vacancies we have an
issue about who how we recruit how we
retain and how we motivate uh our staff
so we're going to have to look at this
pay issue if we're going to have the
Staffing
um that we need and it's not just about
pay it's also about morale it's about
the workload that people have to deal
with but at the moment as an
organization that represents NHS leaders
all I can say is I hope trade unions and
the government continue to talk find a
way through this and if there is more
money to be made available for pay it is
really important that that money comes
into the Health Service because we don't
have spare capacity to meet higher wage
okay thank you so much for being on the
program uh this morning really
interesting to talk Matthew Taylor